aux
saluts tik tok j'ai encore du monde ici
les gars je crois qu'on est de retour
oui
certes mais beaucoup de vélo quand même
ça moi quand même et je me suis dit ces
jeux gonflés mais vous je me suis dit ce
serait une bonne idée que ce soit pas
les roues que je compte
et moi j'ai envie jaa luan avec tout le
respect que j'ai pour elle tous les
français ne gagne pas cinquante mille ou
cent mille euros par concert c'est un
raccourci bruno c'est un raccourci dans
le sens où ce n'est pas parce que tu
gagnes de l'argent que tu dois te la
raconter ça va pas avec ce n'est pas
obligatoire en fait c'est que tu peux tu
peux gagner de l'argent et à braine
c'était une vie très simple moi par
exemple j'ai une belle maison ma voiture
est simple mon style de vie est simple
je me fais certainement des plaisirs
effectivement je voyage beaucoup ce que
c'est ma passion mais je suis simple jeu
je peux manger au snack du coin comme
dans un grand restaurant c'est pas un
problème c'est ça être simple c'est une
attitude c'est pas une question d'argent
au delà de ça je me sens pas au dessus
des gens comme loi 9 son vote des gens
je connais très bien
et au mal pourquoi pourquoi les bossus
il sorte qu'elle doral
quoi il sorte qu'elle de rage parce que
[Musique]
y'a bosse je bosse je bosse
vous présenter comment il fait quoi leur
âge les flaques non salifou drogue
[Musique]
ils sont incertains
le monde
telstar tech
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sur cette pompe est un truc de fou il ya
eu
prescription je peux le dire maintenant
ça fait assez longtemps
il ya beaucoup de gens qui ont vomi
auquel beaucoup d'invités ont des
gueules et où j'ai vraiment tenu les
cheveux de beaucoup d'invités la
personne qui vend le plus beau me je
suis désolé vas-y j'espère que ça va pas
trop se partagent et toi mais le top du
vomi c'est elodie frégé l'aise ledit
frégé avant manque beaucoup beaucoup de
vomi et j'en suis pas fier c'est à cause
de moi